def
シーン
私は
病院や老人ホームなど
医療福祉施設のインテリアリハビリテーションに取り組んでいます
あと心さまざまな側面からつなげて医療や介護をよりよいものにしていこうとする
取り組みです
自分ではつなげたつもりでした
でも振り返って考えてみると
これまでの自分の経験が
導かれるようにつながれてかぶりついた
そういう感覚なんです
折しも
今回のてデックス不幸かのテーマ
アンインター rapty たーーー
意味は途切れない連続した普段のということです
これはつながっていることとも言えますよね
今日は私の活動インテリアリハビリテーションを通して
つなげるという要素ひもときながら
あなたの
アンインターぴと考えてみませんか
いつの時代も私たちに求められることが何かと何かをつなぎ合わせて新しい価値を
生み出すことだと思うからです
ではまずは仕事上の経験をつなげたことに関してお伝えしていきましょう
病院のリハビリテーション部門で理学療法士として勤務していたときのことです
香留依お稽古ごとの間隔でインテリアスクールに話を聞きに行きました
その時ちょうど北欧の福祉と狭いを視察して帰ったばかりだったスクールの先生が
こんな風に言われたんです
デンマークで見た
車椅子ご利用者の方の
オタクのインテリアがとっても素敵で美しかっ
あなたのように病院でリハビリの仕事しているような方がインテリアを勉強するのって
とっても素敵だと思う
てっ
この時私は自分の仕事とインテリアが何か還元があるなんて全く思ってなかったんです
この小さなこの驚きが時そんな小さな
スタートになりました
インテリアコーディネーターの資格を取得した後私は設計事務所に就職します
ここで数多くの医療福祉施設のインテリアデザインを経験させていただきました
ところが
建物が完成して数ヶ月後にお邪魔してみますと
お施主様の思いと
空パンの使われ方
がうまく調和していないなと
そういう感覚を私は受けたんですね
竣工した時は皆さんが喜んでくださったのに
何でなんだろう
考えてみました
私も病院の職員という立場だった頃子だったからこそ気づいたことがあるんです
interior design concept
なこと在職中に聞いたことありません
インテリアの取り扱い方
女がこと学校で勉強なんかしたことないです
作り手の想いは相手に伝わっていないで
そして使う人たちはどうやって使っていいか分からなかったわけですね
したものかと悩みましたけれど
このとき私は何もすることができませんでした
その私は北欧福祉家具の会社に転職します
仕事で何度か塗るレイヤーデンマークの老人ホームを視察する機会がありました
この時インテリアの力は医療福祉施設に欠かせないという思いが改めて強くなったん
です
素朴で暖かくて美しい空間の中で
お年寄りもスタッフもとても居心地4よさそうにしている姿がとても印象的だったん
です
そして2008年私は会社を立ち上げました
理念や想いを大切にするデザインコンサルティング
インテリアを言いをや介護に活かすことができる職員教育
この2つに力を入れて活動しています
仕事データ息づき出会いや失敗秋月こういったことですね
こういったことをつなぎ合わせてつなげて
私は他の人にできない私だけができる
新たな取り組みをスタートすることができました
次は
異なる二つの概念をつなげたことについてです
皆さんは
リハビリテーションについて本当の良いにご存知ですか
とても広い意味があるんですけれども
リハビリテーションというと
機能回復訓練にん
関節の曲げ伸ばしですとかマッサージですとか
あるグリーン種
そういったことと捉えられがちです
語源はラテン語で
り再び等
ハビリス適切にする
空になっています
再び適切な状態にすることを本来あるべき状態に回復することをこういった意味を持つ
んです
居心地の悪い
不調和を起こしている施設のインテリアを再び
適切な状態にすること
この活動をインテリアリハビリテーションと名付けました
そしてインテリアには心という意味もあるんです
インテリアを2して心も元気になるように
それが私の
最終ゴールです
強み興味課題などこういったキーワードをノートにご散りばめまして何と何がつながる
かなぁっていろいろ眺めてたんです
そのときひらめいたのがインテリアリハビリテーションです
これから取り組む新しい活動に素敵な名前をつけることができました
先ほどは仕事上の経験についてお話しましたけれども
3つの個人的な経験これも新しいこのアイデアに大きな影響を及ぼしました
ごめんなさい
一つ目なんですけれども
一つ目はもごめんなさい告白なんですけども私はこんな小さい子供のときから
恋病院嫌いです
こんなに病院の病院がって言ってるのにですね
嫌いっていうよりはが強いんです
すごく
仕事でですねよく訪問しますがその時は大丈夫なんです
でも自分が謹慎するとか受信するってなるともう人一倍ビクビクしています
この状態を自分なりにちょっと解釈してみました
私のこの性質は
病院の良し悪しを図るレーザーとかセンサーになっているかもしれない
だからこそプロではなく一般の人の目線で
環境改善に取り組むことができるんじゃないかなって思えたんです
さらに高校時代
秘蔵ですねっ
部活をしていて靭帯を痛めまして手術入院経験しました
私ばっかりこんなことになっちゃうんだろうってとても悲しい辛い思いもしました
でもこれがきっかけになって理学療法士になりたいって思ったんです
このケガがなければリハビリテーションという
今の活動にもつながるこの考え方に出会うことができませんでした
3番目が
私の父が最後過ごした
病院の記憶です
病室には体力が弱った人を優しく支えてくれるような椅子がありませんでした
居場所といえばベッドしかなくてどんどん弱っていくようでした
表紙の雰囲気も少し暗いイメージで
環境から人を元気にするという仕組みがまったくなかったんですね
のことも私が医療福祉施設のインテリアを改善したいと考え始めたきっかけになったと
思います
苦手なことを大嫌いのことそれから辛くて悲しい経験
こういったことを
克服したり
意味のある体験に何か書き換えられた時私の場合はこれが私の強みになったんですね
思えばどんどん膨らんでいきますけれども実践していくためには仲間の存在が必要です
インテリアリハビリテーションという考え方を理解し行動に移していただくために
私は医療福祉施設における環境づくりという研修を提供し始めました
介護福祉士さんや看護師さんなど病院の現場で働くスタッフさんに学んでいただいてい
ます
インテリアリハビリテーションに取り組むことでただ業務が増えるんだったら
そんなこと誰もやりたくありません
そこで
施設のスタッフさん方に仕事をしていて
どんなことにやりがいを感じているのかを尋ねしてみたんです
患者さんと
患者さんからてに感謝のことがありがとうという言葉をいただけた時
入居しているお年寄りとなにか心が交通路合うような
おしゃべりができたとき
そういったお返事をいただきました
ラフの皆さん方がお仕事をしていて一番得たいと思っている体験
人と人とのふれあい
そのための
時間と
2位を
作り出す方法
それが錦繍の中に盛り込まれているということを理解してもらったんです
例えばなんですけれども生理臭のこれをやることによって業務が効率化されます
そしたら浮いた時間ができて一人一人の患者さんにもっと寄り添うことができますよね
あるいは
飾り方などを勉強してもらうんですけれども
美しく配置されたエイヤー家具
こういったもので談話室がとっても居心地よくなってここに集うことができます
一番得たいと思っている体験のための
時間と舞台を作り出すことができるっていうことをご理解いただきました
ん
このことによって
講師と受講生という間柄ではなく
共にインテリアリハビリテーション実践する仲間になれたような気がしています
最後にこれらの取り組みによってつながったこと
つなげる活動してつながったことをご紹介したいと思います
スタッフの皆さんがインテリアという環境に
アプローチし始めたときその方への援助の仕方がより
俯瞰して見るようになってきたんです
そばに行って寄り添う
少し離れて見守る
言葉かけだけではなくてその人が興味を持ってもらえるような仕掛けを作っていく
そんな形でいい
距離距離感ですねこれを自在に操れるようになってきたんですね
さらに病院や介護の現場というのは非常に専門性の強い
職種の人たちがチームになっています
私の仕事はここまでだからといって協力しないということではなくて逆に違う職種同士
で連携を強めて環境づくりに取り組んでくださったんです
こうして彼らの視点が縦に横に広がってきたんです
さらによりよい環境はスタッフさんと同じような働きもしてくれました
明るくて清潔で美しいお花が飾られたようなエントランスホール
たまたま担当者さんが不在で誰もいなかったとしても暖かく
人を迎えてくれるそんな空間です
今日はいかがされましたかとくーたんが声をかけているような感じなんです
まさに空間=1となったんです
バラバラになりがちな人とば
それに心を調和させ
関係性を見出し
新たな価値として提供した
インテリアリハビリテーション
今少しずつ広がってその効果を発揮し始めています
さあ皆さんも皆さんの a と b をつなぎ合わせてみてください
話を聞きながら
あ
今までそれを意識してなかったけど自分もつなげてたなと
気付いた方もいらっしゃるでしょ
そういうことだったらやってるよって思われる方はさらに c 8 d
こちらを加えてみるのもいいですよね
そしてずーっと後になって自分でつなげたつもりのアイディアが
本当は何かにつなげられたような
そんな感覚になることがあるかも知れませ
私の場合はインテリアリハビリテーションです
想像してみてください
あなたや
あなたの大切な人たちが
つか病院や介護施設で過ごすとき
癒しの空間で
明るい前向きな気持ちで
治療に専念できる
家庭的な雰囲気の中で自分らしく生活できる
そんな環境が当たり前であること
私は現場スタッフのみなさまと共にあなたの5日のその日の為に
インテリアリハビリテーションを実践し続けます
ありがとうございました